I think baby Yoda could be like teenage
Yoda at the end of this the idea there
are clones
Yodas abilities perhaps at the time of
his disappearance transitioned into the
baby Yoda I'm reading mattress this is
rook theory that was terrifying
and today we're laying down our final
predictions for the rise of Skywalker I
am NOT Philip Malina Philip Malina is um
was here this morning I saw him parking
his car but then he went oh I didn't get
a workout in today so then he turned
right around and just left so he
abandoned us to do something way more
important and here we are guys yeah with
me to answer the questions of how we're
gonna do these predictions is of course
Erik Bosse I haven't seen the movie yet
you might have don't judge us oh yeah
and also Danny Bukowski yeah I have seen
the movie but I time is happening all at
once oh yeah you experience yeah you've
seen all movies I've seen all the movies
we're gonna go really rogue about
ghostbusters afterlife yep but first
rise of Skywalker okay we're waiting for
two Star Wars things to come out right
now and we want them to be connected
we're watching the Mandalorian we're
waiting for rise of Skywalker and I want
to know how are they gonna put baby Yoda
into rise of Skywalker are they can they
will they how are they gonna give us
what our deepest heart desires cuz
that's what we all want I think there's
a chance that baby Yoda may not show up
in rises Skywalker as the one that we've
seen on the man Lorien okay but the idea
that there are clones just because the
the doctor on in a Mandalorian
version doctor person is wearing the
same symbol of the people who are sort
of in charge of cloning and yep in
Universal yeah yeah so I think I think
there's a there is a world where some
version of these what's the race what is
Yoda
we go to race yeah I guess I shouldn't
we call him I guess and then we're
calling baby Yoda you know wait he's
just the child right now we don't know
what he's named right he has a name I
was gonna say we can't call him anything
other than baby yeah but we can call him
the child and I just won't all need to
be on the same page and the page we're
all on is baby Yoda but the idea there
could be either the version from then
Lauren or other ones in that universe
the idea is that there would just be
something in the background
probably not affecting plot too much but
the idea like here's something from the
show that is connecting so that these
things sort of our intro over TV
episodes right one can only hope they're
smart yeah I think um I think baby Yoda
could actually be pretty integral to the
plot of rise of Skywalker which I will
see in eight hours so what we'll see
from wrong or not but like we know that
Skywalker's like what does the rise of
Skywalker mean yeah it's a carrot gonna
be related to Skywalker's at a ghost
resurrection we've talked about this
theory that Skywalker is like a
lowercase s it's now gonna be the new
designation of force practitioners the
Jedi Order is dead and that everyone who
does practices in the force now will
just be called Skywalker's either way
some new Jedi Order is going to form and
that this new order for mean imagine Rey
running it her partner in crime being
baby Yoda now a couple years older right
T like 20 years older and we discussed
how baby Yoda ages and that he must age
dramatically between the ages of 50 and
100 based on Yoda's backstory so like
baby Yoda at age 70 is already gonna be
like an adult functioning Jedi Master if
he continues to practice in the force so
yeah I think baby Yoda could be like
teenage Yoda at the end of this kind of
like teenage group yeah but let's be
less moody but maybe the equivalent of
like a human 60-year old who's like
helping ray out in forging this new way
of practicing the foursome and looking
at life I want it I feel like I aged a
little bit like baby Yoda just maturity
wise I think that I'm gonna be who I'm
gonna be like this forever I think that
the linkage the the best linkage I can
imagine between the Mandalorians baby
Yoda and the rise of Skywalker's clearly
Palpatine is still around
that's right the force has sort of a way
of balancing itself out I think we don't
need some chosen one to bring balance to
the force but I think that because Yoda
was like the utmost master of the Jedi's
and the light side and Palpatine was the
utmost master of the dark side if he
never went away
then we shouldn't have really lost that
power in that authority and Yoda the way
we did in the final installment of the
original trilogy so I think that
Yodas abilities perhaps at the time of
his disappearance transitioned into the
baby yoga okay so just like there always
must be exactness and there always must
speak yes yeah that's layer and so and
baby Otis plays if we know one thing I
think that I think that there may then
just be some sort of illusion to baby
Yoda of like well Palpatine still if
Palpatine is still around yeah and also
I mean we do Chuck we mentioned it about
on big question and like go see it if
it's not out or maybe when it's coming
out but like he's for a baby
he's very intuitive about what people
need and want and feel and he wants to
help and baby all the human babies don't
know about that human baby I'm the
center of the universe but baby Yoda
Rick very good intrinsically and like
maybe that species they're like empathy
develops more quickly in those in that
time of their life before like their
language I mean obviously the language
processing part of the brain doesn't
ever get that great oh yeah broken
sentences at best who knows how many
languages he speaks yeah yeah that's
right English could be as 480 second
language we've all been am I really
racist right now Oh racist you are
raised
that's great great oh those are all
really fun and I'm gonna get quantify
them but the amount on was that quantify
the amount of fun that you guys gave me
in blocks of wood so they're different
colors now - they're they are different
colors over someone's getting a silver
one someone's getting a regular rogen oh
you already chose you haven't not chosen
who goes it based on who I like best so
Eric you lose cuz I wore a collared
shirt it's because you look very nice
here seems like a good place to take a
break for our sponsors or maybe it's
just whatever cool things new rock stars
is doing right now
hey wrote Theory listeners if you're
enjoying what you're seeing at rogue
theory but you want some more hard facts
and a bit more booze added to this
formula then you should check out our
new Q&A show the big question where we
go into the really nerdy and kind of
hard to answer but still really
interesting questions like how much
exactly the stores hammer weigh what
happens when Hulk thunder claps why
doesn't Darth Vader force choke everyone
how does baby Yoda age exactly our
lobsters immortal yeah we answer all of
these big questions with some actual
numbers in science yes oh it's a new
show that we're very proud of and
definitely check it out coming to the
channel weekly and you can also
subscribe to the big question podcast
feed to get audio versions of it guys
we're back to the trailer for Ghost
Busters afterlife came out last week and
a hint a lot of connections to the
original two movies so guys how do we
think this movie is gonna connect to the
first two there's probably gonna be
slammer do we do we want there to be a
slammer do we not want yes I do
right now we're discussing opinions yes
I would like I'd like Slimer I would
like that before we get into theories
can I just say they gave me chills yeah
it was nice kind of scary vibe they yeah
you know the opening of the first
Ghostbusters was kind of like a horror
movie we didn't know it was funny yet
yeah
seems like we're going back there yeah
so here's my theory I think the the
original idea for Slimer according to
you know Ivan Reitman and Ramos and
Ackroyd and all those guys is that it
was a ghost of John Belushi
that's kind of their inside joke is that
like you know he's a party animal eats
all the food he's kind of in his piggish
in the way he's he's hilarious super
funny so I think when they were and
talks over the decades to do a
Ghostbusters three before the 2016 one
came out like Bill Murray said he would
only do it if he was a ghost and then
like he kept like conflicting with the
studio because like well we don't want
to kill you off he's like no I'd be much
funnier if he does maybe he goes so I
think I'm probably gonna do that he was
pressured by Sony's lawyers to make a
cameo in the 2016 so this one I think
like the fact that it's jason reitman
it's ivan reitman son i think like all
of the surviving like ramos obviously no
longer with us but I think like Ernie
Hudson Aykroyd and Murray are all gonna
be like in Slimer versions in this movie
like ghost versions of them I don't I
don't want to see a Slimer Sigourney
Weaver though yeah I think she might be
alive I mean it sounds like everyone
with the exception of Rick Moranis
but any pots is gonna come back I think
some of them will be alive but the
Ghostbusters the actual like guys who
jumps into like they're all gonna have
passed away the lore of the ghost has
always been confusing to me because some
ghosts are just like spectral versions
of their human cells and some things are
Slimers which like what the hell and
there's like skeletons driving cabs like
yeah I mean maybe though maybe though
there are like certain spirits that are
the spirits of are we giving too much
credit like there are certain spirits
that are like just the spirits of dead
folks and then there are spirits that
are coming from like the go servers or
like that other plane where we've got
demons the goes reverse point that
coined that that's my copyright nobody
takes it
discussed before this that like the fact
that like the 2016 all-female
Ghostbusters still exists they're in a
different universe than the ones with
Stanton Spangler and all them so like
are we gonna see like a ghost bus or a
buster verse like where we see separate
realities where the Ghostbusters were
different or the Ghostbusters I'd watch
that yeah or were different races or
just like or were ducks yeah Howard the
Duck oh I'm supposed to cross Oh how are
the duck Ghostbuster cross ah or 1985
Tulsa Oklahoma yes Eric that was great
but because I don't like you that much
you only get a quarter is handicapped
good or bad in golf it determines how
many strokes you get an advance it's an
or bad if you have a if a high hand you
get a handy no it's because he's great
but it means too much so it's fewer
point I get a handicap yeah so when I
first read the like synopsis for this
movie and my like knee-jerk reaction was
it says something about like oh this is
the family and the children learned
something about their their grandfather
my knee-jerk reaction was well they're
the children of Slimer obviously but
because like that would be amazing if
Slimers somehow was able to have progeny
but i know i think you can't based on
the trailer it seems like the in the
closet goes it seems like the the
uniform they see in the closet is
Spangler so the presumption is that
these are you know his his great
grandchildren or great-grandchildren
Jerry kakeru-kun would be his daughter
mm-hmm I need his grandchildren so I
think that's like the base way that it's
connected but I also think there are
other elements like Shandor who was the
architect who originally built the
building that Dana lived Ivo Shandor Ivo
Shandor
is also on a name apparently it's also
he's and he's the one who is in charge
of this mining
chef sander mine where the the green
things that look like Slimer are sort of
like flying at us
so I think there those are gonna be sort
of the connections there anymore
I mean I think there is there are gonna
be people popping up as cameos but I
think in terms of actually narrowed it
through I don't know how much of a side
from those things will be connected but
that's like very soft like that makes
sense it's solid and like it I feel like
this movie is trying to like have us
take it a little more seriously and be a
little scarier which for horror fans
like myself I'm very into like I would
like to I would like to be genuinely
scared at some point during this movie
oh that's great this very solid there
you go because I like it and I'm taking
it it's making me be invested I'm in my
initial thing was Rogen the rest of it
wasn't that rogue that Slimers that's
how we got yeah I I really I have more
of like just things that I want to see
besides like actual theories and like
the number one thing that I want to see
is more excellent names like Ivo shane
and vince clortho keymaster of gozer
accession slaps I love it oh my gosh I
want to see some really weird names and
I hope that's the way we can get to that
is through like they've defeated
Gozer like they cross the beams to like
destroy the portal and blow up the big
marshmallow man and Ivo Shandor like I
guess in the deep canon yeah like in the
videogame he like discards his tie to
that destructor God and makes himself
into a destructor and like I really want
to see his or his cults attempts to
bring out a new God from the pantheon of
goes because obviously Gozer has her
demigods vince clortho and Zul i want to
see like what are the other gods in this
pantheon you know what are their names
what are their freakin rad names dude do
they are they gonna come about as a
giant Korg
for that you guys remember Rick Moranis
like describing all the like
manifestations of gozer because I just
like died yes so good like because it's
because it still has to do with ghosts
and because the movie is titled
afterlife yeah oh yeah I sort of want to
see like the God of the Dead or like the
God of like the afterlife from pantheon
yeah I want to see something that's not
like as blatantly horrifying as a
destructor but maybe just like scary
because it's crossing the lines between
the afterlife and the tangible material
realm
Makenna grace going the River Styx
what's going on yeah you get a quarter
because it's just a list of things you
wanted yeah but there is so we remember
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man all right
but I want to know what is gonna be the
new like Stay Puft Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man like what giant thing are we gonna
see what should it be
it's the Geico gecko oh that's so good
that's great or like a Twinkie like a
giant Twinkie Twinkie yeah but it's not
mobile so just [ __ ] just rolls oh it's
gonna go on everybody yeah that's always
fun about the marshmallow man yeah it's
good on everyone marshmallow man kids
stop going wow this could be the sexiest
he's a sailor I'm out of quarter oh geez
so there you go Wow that's right that's
really make you laugh he found the key
surrender one of mine Oh God okay great
guys recap your point totals cuz it's
time for real questions
I'll go first I have 300 keys
this is very different from last no I've
got two and a quarter to five I believe
I am two roadies and I've just grown to
giant size these are normal size where
all my quarter I've grown four times I'm
roughly the size of a bar she ate eggs
Watchmen that's right there you go okay
finale by the way don't worry Eric you
could still win because we have real
questions I hate that it's anyone's game
I want to be my game I want to be in the
bag right now hate rules don't worry you
guys haven't seen these questions and
neither have I so rogue question number
one Disney is rebooting home alone with
the kid from Joe Joe Rabbit
Oh what changes get made to modernize
home alone and more specifically this is
not written on the card but I want to
know what traps are he is he gonna do
it's all Internet of Things enabled
devices he's just gonna be like yeah I
like this maybe this is Doug but he's
like paralyzed in a bed and he's
controlling them all with his mouth like
he's got one of those straws just like
he's just like he's just like mastermind
yeah yeah
great I mean I think a big wave of pop
culture in 2019 had sort of been aimed
that uh you know white supremacist and
whatnot so I think maybe the people
trying to break in and so they're
neo-nazis and he is taken down and I do
kind of agree with you he's marelize in
that like I view them that he's
paralyzed
no I agree with them that like I think
technology is gonna is there's gonna be
a huge step oh yeah and so there's so
much like automation of things in the
house that he'll be able to like oh I'm
gonna turn the a/c way up in this room
and make them and freeze them the boy
all the traps are gonna make the dudes
do fort night dances and he's gonna make
really great tik toks using like
security cameras around the house and
yeah I think the little boys gonna
murder them immediately stand your
ground laws or something George hi row
question number two die hard is a
Christmas movie but it's not one you can
really watch with the whole family give
me your best g-rated version of Bruce
Willis's famous line yippee-ki-yay I was
the baby and look who's talking you just
put that over you stop that over
yippee-ki-yay baby Yoda insert
pop-culture reference funny of course
number three this is our last episode
before Christmas oh yeah give me your
best nerd Santa Claus impression okay so
it's Santa but he's a nerd oh cool cool
who did this Santa exists in the Marvel
Universe I think like Santa shows up and
some more okay just give me a version of
Santa Claus that is not your typical
Santa Claus like new doing an impression
of a new Santa Claus and also with the
nerdy Santa Claus it could be a nerd but
also if I can guess who your Santa Claus
is based on the impression then you get
definitely get a Rogi or some some kind
of prize our worst Christmas ever
I also should have said I'm bad at
reference
[Laughter]
children I'm putting your presents under
a tree
I've got cold to put in your stockings
where do you pants what are you doing
absolutely
where's my mother cookies and my milk
Shrek do you know I saw Shrek ever after
he's agreed on reddit that Shrek is the
most attractive animated he is loved and
worth life that's an insane thing
excellent reddit threads sure someone's
like who do you guys think is the most
attractive animated character and
everyone agreed this is a terrible
question and everyone answered Shrek
after this is over I'm gonna show you
guys shrek is love shrek is life he is
thick and he is sexy but okay but if
it's not shrek then who is it
are you going with shrek it is shrek
okay the most attractive
yeah the most attractive no have a
different answer it's it's a it's Slimer
from the Ghostbusters cartoon it's the
woolly coat from the areal ghostbusters
what about the gorilla from ghostbusters
yeah nobody is saying Robin Hood from
the animated movie trap shrek takes that
cake that box box Leo wins though cuz
right cuz what's this for and it's just
two in two quarters because my scale
tells me that I'm not a giant that's
just a rogue a with two hats great so
Leo wins and he gets his wish Danny you
don't get your wish Erik you don't get
your way oh and
which is oh no is that I control marinas
Twitter until the end of the episode
I'll give it to happy days before
Christmas everyone oh my God look at
that way think marina wrote that oh boy
thanks for watching
three guys clearly we haven't planned
anything out he's doing it in real time
[Laughter]
Twitter tell us where we can find you on
you can find me on Twitter at Leo agent
Garcia but you can also find me at a
indieWIRE comm podcasts in video I'm
making a new Twitter account oh man I
feel so bad for editors who to bleep out
all of these you find me a da vas and be
sure to watch our diehard breakdown this
Christmas Eve cuz die hard is a
Christmas movie that's right guys I'm
Rina master so I'm not fillable inna but
one day I might be if I work out hard
enough there's been rock theory by
[Music]